après le sénat et les questions
d'actualité que vous venez de suivre
retour ici au palais des congrès de la
porte de versailles pour la fin de ce
95e congrès des maires de france à
l'heure qu'il est nous devrions écouter
le discours de clôture de ces rencontres
prononcé par marylise lebranchu la
ministre de la réforme de l'état et de
la décentralisation
mais ce discours a été presque
immédiatement interrompu à son départ
par les salariés de psa aulnay ce s'est
passé il ya trois quarts d'heure environ
vous pouvez voir sur ces images le grand
auditorium du palais des congrès au
moment même où une centaine de salariés
en colère de l'usiné d'aulnay évolué
bien voyez sur ces images interrompre le
discours de la ministre qu'elle devait
prononcer donc pour la clôture de ce
congrès la france
maryse lebranchu qui est obligé de
s'arrêter avec autour d'elle l'ensemble
du bureau et des responsables élus de
l'association des maires de france avec
à leur tête jacques pélissard et ses
nombreux vices présidents discours
interrompu donc envahissement de la
scène de la scène du grand auditorium
vous allez le voir dans quelques
instants sur ces images une centaine de
salariés avec banderoles et j'ai de
tracts une première en tout cas dans un
congrès comme celui ci alors s'en est
suivie une vingtaine de minutes où la
ministre marylise lebranchu et les
responsables de l'association des maires
de france ont négocié directement vous
le voyez sur ces images avec le leader
du mouvement jean pierre mercier le
leader syndical ici avec jacques
pélissard pour négocier le retrait de
ces manifestants du grand auditorium de
la porte de versailles
en tout une vingtaine de minutes devant
une salle comble une salle qui resté
extrêmement calme au moment où je vous
parle et bien tout est rentré dans
l'ordre les salariés en colère d'aulnay
sous bois ont quitté le grand auditorium
après avoir
aussi et après avoir obtenu grâce à
marylise lebranchu un rendez-vous daté
avec le ministre du travail michel sapin
et dans la foulée bien la ministre
présente pour conclure ses travaux du
congrès des maires et bien a repris son
discours et c'est précisément ce
discours de clôture du 95ème congrès des
maires de france que je vous propose
d'écouter tout de suite marylise
lebranchu
même si les moyens sont toujours
difficiles and mail je crois que nous
sommes aussi nous solidaires des gens
qui perdent leur travail
je crois que ça ne doit jamais conduire
à la violence ils ont montré qu il
suffit d'obtenir un rendez vous avec une
date et une heure pour se retirer de la
salle donc je le remercie aussi d'être
reparti maintenant nous avons attendu je
vais essayer d'enchaîner alors le
problème c'est que j'ai aussi des
horaires et je vous parlais du haut
conseil des territoires et je pense que
justement peut-être les reconversions
industrielles des sites aulas a lieu
dans lequel il fera discuter puisque les
salariés nous faisait remarquer à quel
point il avait été choqué de la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
parce qu'on leur avait dit à l'époque je
supprimer la taxe professionnelle
c'était rendre la compétitivité et que
les licenciements ont quand même lieu
donc c'est vrai que nous pourrons aussi
à notre tour parler de tout ça ensemble
pour les collectivités concernées aulnay
en particulier cette concertation dont
je vous parlais se déclinera aussi sur
les territoires donc je vais un peu
accéléré mais vous essayez de vous
redire comment les choses vont se passer
puisque il me semble important que les
communes les régions les départements
les intercommunalités qui seront
représentés discutent du projet tel que
nous l'avons nous écrit avant que les
arbitrages des différents ministères
soit rendue et avant que le parlement
naturellement sans doute le fasse
évoluer mais sur chacun de vos
territoires nous essaierons d'échangés
sur le projet lui-même revenant à au
coeur du projet notre notre base de
d'écriture de ce projet de
décentralisation c'est de dire que si la
république est une et indivisible
les territoires eux sont divers les
territoires ruraux en bas ils sont en
montagne ils sont mères ils sont
métropole ils sont outre-mer ils sont en
campagne au quartier et la loire
connaîtra cette diversité et la capacité
des territoires à s'organiser en tenant
compte justement de cette diversité que
l'on ne s'y trompe pas ce n'est pas un
élément de complexité supplémentaire
mais bien de simplification puisqu'il
s'agit d'une organisation adaptée au
plus près des réalités locales et de la
vie quotidienne des habitants de nos
territoires sur quelques exemples plus
concrets je peux m'en expliquer par
exemple la collectivité chef de file
pour l'économie sera la région on va lui
confirmé son rôle important mais elle
pourra danser dans la concertation avec
vous avec les départements
elle pourra mettre en oeuvre cette
politique économique en partenariat
est il nécessaire quand on est région
qu'on doit discuter de stratégie
d'industrialisation régional de filière
est il nécessaire par exemple de
s'occuper de l'immobilier d'entreprise
peut-être pas donc voilà des ou
d'aménagement de zones d'activités voilà
des déclinaisons de la compétence
développement économique que vous
discuterez avec la région chacun disant
moi je prends tel ou tel pas de l'action
le département lui restera le chef de
file incontesté des solidarités sociales
mais si le besoin s'en fait sentir sur
un territoire si une commune wind ou une
intercommunalité le souhait le
département pourra s'il ya un accord des
deux lui déléguer la compétence par
exemple ou l'insertion des bénéficiaires
du rsa
voilà comment les choses vont se passer
parce que tout ça doit résulter d'une
volonté partagée jamais d'une obligation
l'état lui même pourra confier des
départements sur leur territoire bien à
d'autres telle ou telle action par
exemple et c'était une de vos questions
posées il ya deux jours ici pendant la
table ronde l'ingénierie technique
certains départements ne demande demande
à l'état de pouvoir
un supporter ou porter d'ingénierie
technique responsable de la mise en
place documents d'urbanisme et autre
perspective
si des départements veulent le faire si
les intercommunalités sont d'accord si
les maires en sont d'accord s'il ya une
vraie discussion sur le territoire alors
je dis pourquoi pas puisque déjà
quelques départements l'ont fait en
revanche ce que le président de la
république est venu dire l'autre jour
c'est que certains s'inquiètent et on
leur répond la thése ap verra encore des
conventions bien évidemment pour 2013 et
nous nous engageons derrière le
président de la république est ce que
cette convention soit signée au plus
vite parce que vous les attendez c'est
exemple illustre bien à quel point c'est
la souplesse qui permettra localement
d'assurer la clarté et la cohérence de
l'action publique et les conférences
territoriales de l'action publique
seront là pour construire une
architecture partager accepté éclair de
l'action publique
cette confiance et la responsabilité
bien sûr qu'elle entraîne c'est aussi la
contrepartie on rétablissement de la
clause générale de compétences pour les
régions et les départements que le
président de la république a confirmé
mardi
naturellement et communes prendront part
à ces conférences territoriales comme
les autres collectivités grâce à un
collège qui doit garantir leur
présentation et ce sera un des sujets de
discussion avec votre association
le temps de l'intercommunalité de
projets de services et aussi notre
réalité partagée
il faut donc approfondir poursuivre
l'élargissement et nous sortirons je le
sais dans la concertation dans le
respect des élus municipaux de la
question des périmètres qui avait sans
doute été ces derniers mois la plus
difficile mais il faut aussi créer des
conditions du bon fonctionnement de
l'intercommunalité à tous les points de
vue au niveau d'abord de la mise en
oeuvre de son projet de territoire au
niveau de ses ressources niveau de sa
gouvernance et ce par souci de cohérence
avec l'application de leur statut par
souci d'efficacité
par souci de lisibilité pour nos
concitoyens et les communes membres
là encore vous
or ne m'en fais confiance aux élus pour
qu'aboutisse le projet construit
collectivement pour les habitants qui
résident dans vos intercommunalités et à
ce titre le projet intercommunal
constitue sans aucun doute le bon
véhicule de la mutualisation à laquelle
faisaient référence tout à l'heure
monsieur le président et dont il avait
pour laquelle pardon il avait organisé
un excellent colloque
cette mutualisation a progressé elle
doit encore se poursuivre et même si
elle ne produit qu'à moyen terme des
économies pour les communes elle
produira forcément des effets
structurels pour le service des usagers
et cet effort d'évolution de
l'organisation est d'autant plus
nécessaire au sein du bloc communal que
l'essentiel des compétences exercées
consiste en des services de proximité
qui sont les plus sollicités par nos
concitoyens veillons également ensemble
à ce que la mutualisation ne s'arrête
pas à la signature des conventions de
mise à disposition
elle doit se mettre en oeuvre
concrètement avec les agents je sais je
parlais tout à l'heure de leur
inquiétude ça fait partie de leur
inquiétude s'organiser sera également
nécessaire pour réussir la belle réforme
des rythmes scolaires que porte vincent
peillon notre ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'est une réforme attendue par
la majorité des parents d'élèves est
attendue depuis longtemps puisque je
crois qu'il ya une quinzaine d'années
maintenant qu'on discute des rythmes
scolaires et que les études sont faites
vous avez été entendus sur la nécessité
d'une aide financière de l'état
un président de la république l'a donc
annoncé mardi après midi
nous avons discuté de cette mise en
oeuvre notre objectif partagé avec les
parents d'élèves de france et en tenant
compte de tous cas être pu être dit par
ailleurs c'est qu'un minimum de
collectivités demandent la dérogation
pour 2014 nous prendrons acte de
difficultés et elles seront étudiées il
y en a en revanche ce que nous voudrions
c'est à nouveau faire différence entre
les collectivités qui pourront répondre
à
c'est facilement à la nouvelle
organisation et celles qui ont plus de
mal et donc on reverra avec dans la
concertation
la répartition de ces 250 millions
d'euros qui pourront permettre aux uns
et aux autres de faire face à des
difficultés générées par la mise en
place en 2013 de la semaine de quatre
jours et demi
vous aurez monsieur le président à
discuter avec nous des clés de
répartition c'est toujours un peu
difficile vous le savez mais nous y
arriverons ensemble à un moment de notre
histoire où la maîtrise de la dépense
est impératif nous devons état et
collectivités locales donc trouver des
leviers pour dégager des marges de
manoeuvre vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
de confier aux communes les outils
juridiques et financiers pourraient
parvenir je crois que l'état doit aux
communes de france
les outils juridiques et financiers que
vous demandez l'état doit leur garantir
le bon fonctionnement au quotidien et
beaucoup de maires s'interroge sur les
sources d'économies qu'il pourrait
encore faire que les forces
supplémentaires sur la fiscalité locale
qu'ils demandent à leurs habitants
atteint ses limites
alors que les besoins croissent de jour
en jour quand il devient aussi chaque
année plus difficile de boucler le
budget et c'est sans aucun doute parce
que nous le pensons vraiment et vous le
partagez je crois les ressources ne sont
pas assez bien répartis entre les
communes de france et entre les
intercoms de france la péréquation doit
donc contribuer à y remédier la
péréquation le maire de paris le disait
à la tribune la péréquation c'est
l'effort de solidarité entre les
collectivités sur leurs propres
ressources
elle doit donc reposer sur des critères
simples et critères justes les critères
stable françois pupponi qui doit déjà à
conduire une réflexion sur la réparation
de la dde
si l'accès sera en charge de suivre ses
clés de répartition de la péréquation
qu'ils sont sans doute trop peu lisible
pour l'ensemble des maires de france
nous allons essayer de les écrire
mieux il faut prendre en compte la
richesse fiscale bien évidemment mais il
faut prendre en compte
revenu moyen au revenu médian
disions-nous l'autre jour mais il faut
bien prendre en compte aussi les charges
charge particulière de certaines
communes petit mais qui sont au centre
de communes encore plus petit et nous
devons aussi prendre en compte des
territoires les plus fragiles
à ce titre-là des clés de péréquation
seront je l'espère encore plus justes
l'an prochain gouvernement a pris aussi
ses responsabilités en doublant la
progression de la dotation de solidarité
urbaine et de la dotation de la
solidarité rurale
dès l'année prochaine vous en aviez
besoin c'est une dépense supplémentaire
que le président de la république et le
premier ministre nous ont demandé de
faire nous devons aussi penser à vos
investissements et président pélissard a
beaucoup donné avec d'autres ici
présents pour qu'enfin voit le jour une
agence de financement des collectivités
locales
nous avions un souci partagé qui celui
des les comptes de l'état vous
connaissez la situation de la france est
pas aussi bien que moi sans doute et
nous ne pouvions pas donné de feu vert à
ce travail de création des agences sans
lever l'hypothèque de la garantie de
l'état et donc il fallait passer jeu
grâce de la technique
un établissement public à un
établissement plus coopératif plus
mutualistes mais le président de la
république a donné son accord
donc dès lundi reprenant le chantier il
y aura une agence de financement des
collectivités locales je le souhaite et
nous devons y arriver ensemble jeu mais
je ne m'en réjouis d'autant plus qu'il
s'agit d'une initiative des communes et
des collectivités locales
l'initiative ne viennent pas de l'état
elle vient du terrain bravo à vous
monsieur le président je ne me connais
le certes pas votre votre engagement sur
ce dossier mais je ne méconnais pas non
plus votre engagement sur les demandes
de financement des investissements parce
que il ya eu des soucis dexia fait
partie maintenant malheureusement de
nombreux paysages partager
vous avez vu que nous avons
d'arrache-pied et je remercie les mises
et l'économie des finances et ministre
du budget de leur implication réussi à
régler un certain nombre de dossiers au
niveau européen ils ont bien travaillé
mais il fallait au delà de cela que la
caisse des dépôts et consignations dont
on a élargi la ressource en touchant au
plafond délivrer des femmes puissent
répondre aux collectivités territoriales
l annonce de passer de 12 milliards à 20
milliards les fonds dédiés aux
collectivités locales n'est pas metz
annonce parce que ce que j'entends le
plus sur le terrain c'est à la fois la
difficulté de trouver des petits prés
pourra y remédier mais j'entends
beaucoup de communes d'intercommunalité
se plaindre de ne pas trouver de des
prêts à un taux intéressant et sur une
période longue
en particulier pour des équipements très
structurant cynisme en lots sont parfois
des castes est difficile et donc nous
nous engageons sur l' enveloppe
supplémentaire à vous garantir des
emprunts des prêts pardon à long terme
avec des taux d'intérêts intéressant on
me dit tu n'iras pas quand même jusqu'à
35 en bray bien pourquoi pas sur un
certain nombre d'équipements
structurants
nous devons avec la caisse des dépôts et
consignations prendre en compte la
lourdeur de certaines charges par
rapport à la possibilité de les financer
donc vous avez eu gain de cause et je
vous remercie de nous avoir non pas
occupé sur la scène avec des micros mais
nous avoir frappé quasiment tous les
jours à notre porte pour avoir
satisfaction
vous l'avez et j'en remercie aussi au
passage je ne vais pas fait le président
de la république qui nous soutient dans
cette recherche là mais il connaît bien
les communes en particulier communes
rurales il faudra aussi chercher avec
les villes un rôle particulier vous
l'avez
dit dans votre relevé de résolution et
je vous en remercie parce que on a trop
longtemps opposé ferment effet rural je
trouve que c'est de très bonnes chances
pour l'avenir que l'association des
maires de france reconnaisse avec nous
le fait métropolitain avec des
communautés très intégrée qui verront
leur statut renforcé mais qui ont aussi
beaucoup plus de responsabilités par
rapport à leur territoire et la loi
d'ailleurs précisera au demeurant des
évolutions spécifiques je pense à lyon
je pense à marseille par exemple nous
avons quelques grands dossiers
je veux dire partager avec allégresse
parfois pas beaucoup d'enthousiaste mais
nous y arriverons
je voudrais voilà marylise lebranchu la
ministre de la réforme de l'état de la
décentralisation qui vient d'achever son
discours de clôture de ce 95e congrès
des maires de france ici porte de
versailles à paris
une dernière a promis d' congrès marque
et vous l'avez vu il ya quelques minutes
sur notre antenne par une manifestation
des salariés d'aulnay sous bois qui ont
envahi la grande salle plénière de ce
congrès merci beaucoup
jacques pélissard d'être avec nous
président de l'association des maires de
france c'est la première est la première
fois qu'il ya un incident de ce type
lors d'une journée de congrès oui mais
vous savez tout se passe au congrès des
maires de france
les annonces présidentielles ministériel
tout ça se passe au congrès des maires
de france c'est un moment important de
notre vie politique nationale et c'est
un lieu effectivement on peut essayer
d'attirer l'attention sur soi
c'est ce qu'ont fait les ouvriers de
d'aulnay crois que l'on peut nous
entendu ils ont libéré les dieux ensuite
dont on continue nos travaux de façon
efficace et calme
absolument alors il ya un de leurs
slogans qui nous interpellait élus et
salariés
nous avons parfois les mêmes intérêts
vous partagez cette phrase oui parce que
les élus défendent partout l'emploi
quand on fixe un projet d'investissement
canton créneau industriel quand on fixe
également les taux de contribution
française entreprises
on a toujours en ligne de mire l'emploi
l'activité économique la compétitivité
de notre territoire
donc les mêmes
sont convaincus que par le fait que
c'est bien l'emploi qui est aussi avec
d'autres données l'une de leurs
priorités
sreg l'emploi l'environnement
l'urbanisme on a effectivement tout et
enregistre d'action mais l'emploi est
l'un de ceux qui nous tient le plus au
coeur jacques pélissard j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya eu beaucoup plus
de mer que d'habitude aujourd'hui leur
dos au congrès en particulier mardi lors
de la venue du président de la
république françois hollande il y
beaucoup de maires cette année encore
encore plus génial hier et beaucoup de
maires studieux moi ce qui m'a frappé
c'est la présence de tous les maires
dans les ateliers dans les débats avec
une participation que je n'avais encore
jamais vu ça prouve l'intérêt que
suscitent les cons le congrès des maires
de france ça prouve que ensemble les
mères travaillent échanges apprennent et
repartent avec le bon moral dans leur
commune au delà de l'affluence
un môme est vraiment un mot de bilan de
ce congrès on en a déjà parlé avec de
nombreux élus ici même le bilan c'est de
beaucoup d'avancé des réussites sur
certains points des réponses précises
sur la jambe de financement des
collectivités
c'était essentiel pour nous sur l'école
sur les normes
bref un cadre intéressant que nous avons
réussi à forger qui peut nous permettre
à demain d'être plus efficace encore
dans nos communes et intercommunalités
et donc il se passe vraiment toujours
quelque chose au congrès de
l'association des maires de france merci
mille fois
jacques pélissard d'avoir été avec nous
pour clore ce 95ème congrès merci mille
fois vous d'avoir été avec nous sur
l'antenne de public sénat en direct
toute cette semaine pour suivre les
débats pour suivre les ateliers pour
suivre les demandes les préoccupations
les soucis des 36000 élus locaux des
36000 maires de france merci évidemment
à l'ensemble de l'équipe
l'équipe technique de public sénat qui
nous a permis de réaliser cette émission
merci mille fois de votre fidélité
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
sur notre antenne c'est bientôt à 19h le
journal présenté par michel grossiord
merci